i think we can recreate the famous
trench run scene from a new hope in a
day our idea is to do it as easily and
casually as possible while still having
it look better than the original movie
you guys better be careful because
disney might be coming after you
there is nothing i like better than
looking at old visual effects and
imagining all the sweat blood and tears
that went into doing those old visual
effects and then flippantly and casually
recreating the same visual effects in a
day we've done it with tron we've done
it with terminator 2 and now we're going
to do it with star wars specifically the
trench run because back in the day when
they made this trench for unseen it was
a lot of work because there weren't
really any computer effects in fact the
only computer effect in the original
star wars a new hope is the wireframe of
the death star when they're discussing
death star plans i think we can recreate
the famous trench run scene from a new
hope in a day particularly because of
the help of fenner here i'm fenner
rockliffe i'm a compositor primarily
worked as kind of a cgi generalist down
here visiting the quarter crew this week
arguably federer does more professional
stuff than we do he's working in things
like nuke he's working at vfx houses
he's worked on some tv shows so with a
little bit of this like professional mix
in with like the road we should be able
to bang out a pretty cool death star
transform scene our idea is to do it as
easily and casually as possible while
still having it look better than the
original movie well let's take a look at
the original trench run and break it
down just a little bit here and we'll
pick out a little sequence to do okay
here we go this is an amazing shot this
could be probably one of the most
amazing shots from the french run
we should we should do this shot yeah i
think we have to do this shot now one
thing i'm noticing also is the lasers
don't cast any light these bright beams
of plasma energy are not illuminating
the trench at all it would be really
cool to see them fly down the trench and
see that glow yeah get some of that
interactive lighting maybe this is a
good ending point
okay so this explosion that we're
looking at here you can see the blue
spill on it very clearly what they're
doing is they're filming a model and an
explosion on the blue screen and then
keying out the blue but it's not a
perfect key by any means what would be
cool is to see an explosion that doesn't
have blue screen fringing or transparent
smoke possibly even casting light on the
trench around it i think a big part of
it too will be matching the look of
those cg renders to the original footage
oh yeah making it look more filmic i
think that's something we want to
achieve so let's go from swooping into
the trench to the first fly wing being
blown up yeah let's just take some
creative liberties one of us is
responsible for an x-wing one's
responsible for the wildling i'll do the
next thing
yeah sounds good i might handle the y
wing there break all right
before i do the trench run using modern
visual effects techniques i'm going to
simulate doing it the way they had to do
it in 1977. i'm still going to do it in
a 3d program just so i don't have actual
models or a dijkstra flex which is the
computer controlled arm but all the
other steps will be authentic to how
they had to do it when they wanted to do
these shots they had to do it all with
models and they had to do it camera
passes so imagine i'm at ilm and the
model shop has just delivered to me an
awesome star wars trench my gaffing team
my grip team went ahead and set up some
lights and i have a nice point light
there it is whoa it's so bright i also
have a soft box which is this big
rectangle here it's a little dark i'd
have to physically move my light
to be in the right spot but here i can
just slide this virtual light but same
idea so i'm dennis mirren i'm like well
what shot do i want i want to get a shot
looking down on an x-wing as it flies
down the trench and i want to push into
it and then rotate behind it and so i
got my first keyframe here i typed in my
code at the dexter flex and we have the
camera follow along and swoop down and
once again they couldn't do real-time
playback because the computer controlled
arm did not move in real time it was
basically stop motion it moved take a
picture move take a picture move take a
picture so after you program your motion
you can just hit play and watch things
through it'd be like that's cool that's
what i like so i'm going to try to just
not look at the animation i'm just going
to try to dial it in by hand and then
you have to film it on film you don't
get to look at it on a computer screen
you have to wait for the shots to expose
and develop so let's pretend i now have
to wait until tomorrow
okay it's tomorrow
[Music]
let's see how it looks
pretty cool so now notice that i have
like sharp edges in my animation right
it's like mark and it kind of locks in
cinema 4d i can just tell it to smooth
out and average out these motions they
didn't have that they had to like
manually punch in every single position
right click spline
right click spline done
time to get another shot send it off to
the film lab to be exposed
another day has passed my trench is
complete so perhaps in parallel somebody
else is working on the x-wings well next
thing's not the same size of the trench
they haven't been built to scale this
exiting model can be huge so i'm going
to kind of do it how they did just a
little less math and a little more
artistic eye but one thing that's worth
mentioning is they have to film all
their models on a blue screen they'd
have to stick it on a blue stick like
this so if i wanted to simulate this
x-wing flying by me i'd have the x-wing
hold still and the camera would swoop in
the x-ray could fly by so if the model
holds it over the background appears to
move it makes it look like the model's
moving all right so i made my animation
time to see if my shot's cool pretty
freaking janky now i need to go into my
dope sheet in the curve editor and start
working with my plots did i screw it up
who knows
the director came back with notes he's
like you know the x-wing leaves the
bottom of the frame i want you to push
it back just a little bit so i'm adding
some new points here hopefully it worked
out let's get the shot set in the film
lab
[Music]
okay moving a little fast tracker has
more notes slow it down but it's already
locked into the trench run shot we got
boss you approved that earlier i got one
second to make that swoop can't change
it okay cool ready to go wrong
now we need to set the lighting so they
couldn't just copy and paste their
lighting setup from the trench to their
exit models they could take notes they
could try to replicate it but you
couldn't just copy and paste it you
could just save your 3d scene and open
it with new lighting i have a
directional light coming from the left
in the trench shot and i have a soft box
above so now i need to recreate that for
this x-wing softbox is easy enough let's
just put that over the x-wing now what
about like the daylight well here's the
question does the x-wing dip into the
shadow of the trench it does so that
directional light needs to be blocked
off i'm going to have to turn it off
entirely then i'm going to emulate the
bounce light hitting the side of the
trench and eliminating the side of that
the x-wing from the side of the trench
that's all illuminated and there we go
and i have one on the side is it too
bright hard to say this is where you
gotta bust out your light meters and
like okay here it's giving me a read of
this much light on the trench gave me a
read of this much light does it look
right who knows
that's the thing you have to kind of
just guess take my trench shot is what i
have on one film wheel and then i have
this x-wing on another thumbnail so now
i need to ferocious it i need to
composite it so back in the day you
would use a series of different filters
to eventually print a piece of film
that's black and white the background
the blue being black and everything that
is what you want to say being white or
the inverse of that depending on what
stage you're doing we're going to use
basically color keying let's see how
they pair up
not that bad honestly notice the
lighting feels somewhat disconnected
between the two and you'll notice the
exact same look in the original trench
run shots where the models kind of feel
like they're lit a little bit
differently in the background and that's
because they're not in the background
it's because they're just two separate
things have been filmed at separate
times wait wait wait i'm not done yet
you got some lasers let's just do it
like they did get a draw freaking laser
boom classic star wars laser let's just
see that one laser in action
there it is this is how they did it
granted i'm doing the steps on the
computer to simulate how they did it but
you have an idea now of the steps they
had to go through but nellie showed you
the old school way of doing things let
me show you the new school way of doing
things this is the part where i get to
show you all the cool things that modern
technology enables us to do so the very
first thing that we have in advantage
over the guys at ilm for 1977 is there's
a whole bunch of people that love star
wars now and have already made all the
models for us in 3d
so i just went online and i got next
model we found uh just a rough death
star trench chunk that fender then added
bits of grebels of geometry to so here
we have the death star trench and this
is actually just a bunch of little
chunks here that we've copied and pasted
i took that and i made a material for it
that's a mixed material and this gives
me a lot of surface variation i've also
added some little windows and that's
really nice especially when things on
motionboard you get nice little light
streaks after i've done this texture
adjustment i have my trench
so now i want to animate some x-wings
all i need to do is place an object in
the scene screw it from one end to the
other and attach the x-wings to that you
have to wait a whole day you do not have
to wait a whole day and in fact you can
do your animations whenever you want oh
you see those white tubes flying by
those are lasers i built a particle
emitter that shoots lasers in fact i can
aim that particle emitter wherever i
want and i can make multiple versions of
it so i can have multiple laser guns
shooting turrets everywhere and one of
the really cool things about having your
lasers be a part of the physical scene
that you are working on is that those
lasers will cast light onto your objects
directional lighting gives everything
volume and shape and helps you feel the
physicality of it it looks pretty
freaking rad
check this out
the x-wing that's in the top left corner
of this frame that x-wing is casting a
shadow on the side of the death star i
am showing you that those x-wings are in
the same world as this trench and i'm
showing you the scale of the x-wings i'm
showing you how fast they're moving and
how close they are to the wall flex flex
on ilm in 1977.
hey guys it's me jake here in my fighter
jet here to tell you about cord or
digital.com that's right if you like how
we create videos here we have an entire
show called crew cuts with over 80
episodes of vlog style content of us
doing things like this every single day
there's also the greatest dungeons and
dragons show that we made through the
website subscribers called son of a
dungeon it's dropping in september whoa
gotta keep these upright gotta keep
steering this x-wing we also have an
entire show called functional filmmaking
it's an expedition into how we create
things and what our philosophy and
mindset is when we go into creating
content and guess what know as you get
15 off all merchandise we have an
amazing system called producer points
which allows you to put your
subscription dollars into shows that we
want to make everything we do on youtube
it'll always be here but if you want
more head on over to cordaddigital.com
two months free you get if you sign up
for a year that's right i said it like
yoda and i'll say it again two months
free you get when you sign up for a year
what am i where am i am i
[Music]
am in a green screen right now
[Music]
i gotta get back to work
there's a whole bunch more things that
we can do once we are done with our 3d
render so let's go take a look at what
fender's up to and have him tell us all
about what makes nuke so wonderful so
i've been pumping out cool renders
you've been pumping out cool renders
you've been taking those renders into
nuke and really dressing them up with a
whole bunch of additional looks and
effects yeah this runner just came out
of blender cycles right out of blender
it actually looks pretty janky it just
kind of looks like a motion blur mask
and there's not a lot of contrast going
on so this is where i find that nuke is
really helpful as i render with like a
multi-channel exr and then i have
multiple aovs that i can adjust and kind
of dial in the look afterwards you have
your kind of beauty layer here and then
i have my like ambient occlusion and the
other nice thing is too is we can just
isolate out our emissive passes here so
i've got all the kind of lights that are
within the trench and all of the
different lasers as well and this is
really helpful
because then i can kind of do some cool
post effects on the standard stuff like
glows and then get a little bit more in
depth and start to add some kind of like
distortion and heat effects coming off
of it so it makes it more than just the
basic like cylinder laser kind of
particle system that we set up and then
a big thing that we're adding that
really kind of helps sell that filmic
cinematic look is doing a bit of like a
lens dirt setup so i've got a couple
different textures here and we're
basically using these and driving them
by a keyed version of like the luminance
here we get a little bit of kind of that
like natural fall off that you'd see
through a camera lens and then sometimes
if it's bright enough you're going to
pick up an actual little bit of texture
kind of grime on the lens i also like to
just always kind of kiss in some
additional stuff for a shot like this
like lens barreling as if we're kind of
like pinging the kind of edges of our
camera's lens add some vignette to kind
of draw the viewer's eye to where we
want it to go then a bit of healthy dose
of chromatic aberration it helps kind of
give that contrast which again pretty
subtle i also added a little bit of
off-screen flaring and i can find that
like you know that's something if you're
shooting practically you're going to get
that right you're going to have you
don't have to even think about it yeah
it's just going to happen i've got like
a little bit of a lot applied here to
make it look more filmic and then just
kind of a healthy dose of lens
distortion on the bottom there just to
kind of play up a little bit of that
pseudo-anamorphic look to it once we've
got our 235 crop on there you go from
something that didn't look very
cinematic before
[Music]
yeah that's a huge difference and now
because you basically have this node
tree you can theoretically just swap
your input image sequence to a different
image sequence and all this math and
filters and functions that you build
will all still flow through and you'll
end up basically with all these effects
applied to a new piece of footage yeah
just by simply retargeting the very
first code maybe this isn't the correct
way to do this but when we're doing this
in like a week and trying to turn around
a bunch of stuff it's just kind of like
what can we do quickly that's going to
get us to the finish line cool well then
we'll get to have a really cool
side-by-side comparison of the original
shots in the trench run our shots that
we did in just a few days and maybe even
a little sequence where you could see
our shots cut into the movie to see how
they fit stay tuned to see our cool
renders
all right we are joined by sam and
brendan from so chrissy media you ever
heard of shock warfare has like a
bajillion views on youtube well these
are the guys that made it also dean
resin star wars ultra fan though you
might have to fight christian for the
title to see who the real ultra fan is
well i mean just watch back the node
trivia challenge he was there he lost uh
terribly i want to show you guys a
project that fenner and i have been
working on i'm curious to see what you
guys think all right final results oh
yeah we just kind of walked in here we
don't know what to expect so let's see
how this goes i'm really curious here
switch to targeting
[Music]
keep your eyes open for those
spiders you guys better be careful
because disney might be coming after you
it looks incredible like it absolutely
looks incredible the glow on those lens
flares who do the compositing for this
uh right here yeah
who am i
dude that lens player right on the top
that is like the cherry the spice right
yeah spice i like the lens distortion
bulge yeah
it's subtle but it really like makes it
work you see the reflection of like the
death star trench on the canopy whereas
you don't have that in the models
because it filmed separately i think the
biggest difference we're noticing is the
originals there's no interactive
lighting like even some of the shots
where the y wings are in the trench
they're fully lit they're not actually
having any of the shadow from the trench
it's so much more dynamic than the
original shot are there lights on here
like other little emissive zones okay
they actually have it in the real trench
also it's a really nice textural effect
to the trench it's bouncing this way
you're right brandon noticed there's a
it's also softbox right here shiny soft
light down into the trench that's the
reflection of it right there okay yeah
it's obviously it's not visible to the
camera but it is visible the reflections
but you can notice how like the lasers
actually reflect off of artsy's head oh
yeah which is really nice sweet with the
green flares flying by on them and take
a look to my fender shots here total
upgrade like the glow from the engines
on the y-wings i've added in some lights
there and they're just kind of like
parented to the actual models of the
y-wings there so you actually get them
like kind of lighting up the trench as
they're flying through the shadows there
i like the little subtle camera jitter
too making it feel like this camera is
just flying down the trench
oh that looks very hairy no it's a lot
more dynamic you actually have some
rotation happening in there i gotta say
these shots are like high budget tv
quality shots like i agree
with you you know disney like they got a
thousand artists working on it for
months but like you guys whipped up in a
week what could go on hbo
oh yeah that's flashing i will say the
motion looks pretty accurate to the
original star wars movies because then
they have those models on like just a
line and yeah
it was wiggling
this is the shot where you're like all
right now we need like houdini on top of
all this it's one thing to build the
model and make it look nice but then to
build the internals of it have it
actually destroy itself yeah a whole
nother crazy process i think when you
throw some explosives in a model and
just roll the camera you blow it up it's
so much harder to get that same quality
with cgi and you know it is lighting up
the trench behind it smoke is flying off
of it those are things that you can't
really do with models yeah did you say
you guys were gonna remaster the whole
thing though did we just remaster the
entire trench now i feel like been a
couple years since they remastered the
whole thing you know we're due for
another remaster for george mason
so the next video we practically
recreate the trench run
actually that would be pretty cool we
thought we haven't thought about it let
us know in the comments below if you
want to try to practically redo the
trench front or there's another old
movie effect that you want us to try to
reapproach in just a few days using
modern technology
and considers consider subscribing